a Zelda game without dungeons is like a
monster maze with no maze like sure
you've got one hunky netherlander man
running a YouTube channel all by himself
but without the maze where are the
theories where are the analyzes where's
the super sweet dungeon Bandit oh hey
it's Dawn from Monster maze uh how long
have you been standing there exactly a
while I mean you called me to come over
remember you said and I quote Donnie
dude like there's this huge rash on my
back that I need did I say that I don't
remember saying that at all well you did
I even brought some aloe vera well you
know no rashes here definitely not ones
covering my entire back and growing hair
in strange places um hey since you're
here why don't you help me cover the
dungeon lore of Ocarina of Time dungeons
are kind of your thing yeah I guess they
are kind of my thing yeah so let's talk
Dungeons and never mention rashes again
whatever you say man oh and uh by the
way spoiler alert obviously the first
dungeon we're going to fully explain
would be the dadongos cavern located on
Death Mountain oh what's that you're
wondering where the first dungeon in the
game the great Deku Tree is well for the
other half of the dungeons make sure you
visit the video over on my channel after
you're done here there's a ton of lore
in these games so splitting it up into
two videos is just easier or at least
that's what Bandit is scripting me to
say right now good job my puppet good
job yeah anyway most fans know or can
assume correctly that the dongos cavern
is the cave from which the famous the
Dongo dinosaurs originate I mean it is
in the name after all but what's more
obscure about the cavern is the history
surrounding The Disappearance and
reappearance of these fire-breathing
lizards but let's talk about what the
cave is currently used for first before
arriving at speculation station the race
of volcano dwellers that most fans of
the series are very familiar with would
be the boulder-like gorons who in fact
made their first appearance in Ocarina
of Time these Rock people actually eat
rocks which is pretty much their only
source of food and nutrition and to take
things a step further apparently the
only or perhaps best rocks that the
gorons could Feast upon for sustenance
came from the dongo's cavern because of
this it makes sense that the cavern
itself would be a heavily mined area
with tons of rooms and hallways and
levers and buttons and doors and what
have you it's also why after the Goron
leader darunia refused to give Ganondorf
the Goron Ruby the Gerudo king tried to
force them into obeying him by blocking
the entrance to the cavern with a big
rock preventing the gorons from entering
and being able to eat food wait a sec
don't Goron's you know eat rocks why
didn't they just eat the one that
Ganondorf placed in the entrance of the
don't ask questions that don't have
answers Bandit it's easier that way
anyway without easy access to the cavern
the gorons were apparently on the verge
of Extinction yet still they did not
give up on the Goron Ruby though so
Props to them for sticking to their guns
fortunately a 10 year old was able to
enter the cavern by blowing up the
almighty ceiling rock with a single Bomb
Flower and defeating the ancient
dinosaurs inside thus re-enabling
entrance to the cavern and saving the
gorons from their starvation so now for
the more speculative side of things and
Mr Bandit this one's all you well to
start things off we have reason to
believe that the big boulder in the
entrance of the cavern isn't the only
thing Ganondorf did here actually far
from it darunia states that quote
ancient creatures have infested the
dango's cavern this would imply two
things one that the ancient creatures
are in fact the dongos themselves and
that prior to the events happening here
dadongo's Cavern was actually clear of
these ancient creatures hadn't swai
darunia is freaking out about their
reappearance while their reappearance
isn't explained explicitly we can assume
that since Ganondorf also revives
another ancient long since deceased
lizard dinosaur creature later on in the
game named vulvagia also on Death
Mountain that the re-emergence of
dodongos is also due to ganondorf's
Magic in our opinion it was most likely
the ancient Goron hero who wielded the
Megaton Hammer that was responsible for
ridding the volcano of volvagia and all
the dangos long ago the biggest of which
still has its skeleton visible to this
day but that's neither here nor there
another feature of the cavern that's
harder to explain would be the booby
traps located everywhere there are bmo's
enemies sitting ready to fry you if you
enter their gaze and there are rooms
like the razor maze or the one with the
giant staircase that needs to literally
be blown up to be climbable stuff like
this doesn't really fit into the rather
innocent mining for food explanation
yeah I don't think the gorons would need
to booby-trap their Rock food mine when
they're the only species in the world
that mines rocks for food I guess this
one can probably also be chalked up to
the work of Ganondorf you know in the
case the gorons wisened up and ate their
way inside the cavern besides there's
also lisofos inside which are always
depicted as Servants of the forces of
evil so there you have it the history
purpose and events surrounding the
dongo's cavern explained with a nice
little Christmas bow on top moving on
the next dungeon we're going to cover
would be the Forest Temple and this is a
big one that's also been theorized over
for a long long time but again let's
just start off simple by covering what
we know factually about the area in the
game it's an entire hit Hidden Fortress
or castle that's located deep within the
Lost Woods so far into it in fact that
I'd imagine most if not all Wayward
Adventures who may be searching for it
would be eternally lost in the woods
before ever even catching a glimpse of
the temple doomed to turn into stalfos
for the rest of time but for those who
know the way to the sacred grove and
Beyond and who are able to enter they'll
discover that the interior is just as
mysterious as the exterior the temple is
expansive and very obviously handmade
with rooms and rugs and pictures and
torches and also ghosts which haunt the
place literally none of this is
explained even a little bit in the game
and the only connections with the
outside world that we can see would be
the forest Sage icon located above the
entrances of the doors and the Phantom
Ganon boss which is a pretty clear
connection to Ganondorf who obviously
plays for the Phantom Ganon inside the
temple in order to stop the forest Sage
from Awakening the forced Sage being
Saria who entered the Forest Temple due
to her being able to feel an evil wind
blowing out of it must resist making
fart joke also there are some giant
blocks inside the castle that strangely
feature the Gerudo symbol on them but
that is literally the end of everything
we know about the mysterious castle in
the woods at least in game Mr maze let's
get theoretical certainly sir a like
Bandit mentioned the Forest Temple has
been one of the most intriguing and
theorized about pieces of Zelda lore
since the release of Ocarina of Time
over 20 years ago with that said let's
try to come up with a safe conclusion
that wraps up everything going on here
first and foremost what is the purpose
of a castle or Fortress which the Forest
Temple clearly is given its stone block
walls and battlements located on top no
matter how you slice it or what real
life culture you'd like to derive the
answers from a castle is always used for
the purpose of living under a nearly
impenetrable physical protection hence
the sound structures due to the expenses
they're going to creating such a
Monumental piece of safe housing usually
only the very rich and well-off Royal or
noble families could even afford to
build or live in one and in the Forest
Temple the interior of the castle is
also rather nice all things considered
you can tell it's been abandoned for a
while but there's a grand main hall with
an elevator outdoor balconies a gazebo a
well a garden and many more nice things
that were probably there because whoever
built this place was well off speaking
of the builders though I think it's
improbable that the Forest Temple was
put here by the royal family of Hyrule
simply because there's quite literally
no royal family symbolism present
anywhere inside the castle except for
the boss room which is riddled with the
Triforce everywhere on the ground but
we'll get back to that the most obvious
and likely most accurate answer as to
who was responsible for creating this
Majestic Castle would be the four post
sisters present within and for a bit
more proof just look at their clothing
or more specifically the clothing of the
main purple sister Meg none of the other
pose in the game or in the franchise as
a whole for that matter have jewelry but
mag here does it's a very fancy looking
head Jewel like a tiara and historically
Tiaras were worn by royalty especially
in medieval times so automatically we
can come to the conclusion that the
castle was built by a rich family and
that sad family was most likely the PO
sisters now two questions remain who
were the poe sisters and what happened
to them to turn them into you know pose
which are described as hateful lingering
Spirits great question sir let's start
with that first one I think the symbols
of the forest Sage present all over the
place in the Forest Temple is very
telling as to who the poe sisters were
in life and this suggestion may be a bit
shocking to believe but just bear with
me for a moment and also remember that
this is all just my theory and you are
more than welcome to as always believe
whatever you would choose to I'd like to
remind you briefly that there is another
entire group of sages that we've never
seen in game referred to as the ancient
sages of which rauru the sage of light
is the last remaining member we can
assume based on this information that
this likely means that the ancient or
original sages were also each attributed
to their own respective elements such as
forest and water and Shadow and light
and that must mean that the sage of the
forest had an entirely different
identity prior to Syria being awakened
as a sage so what if the old sage of the
forest lived in this this very Temple I
mean Syria even refers to herself as the
awakened Sage of the Forest Temple so
this would only make sense plus there's
a Triforce warping pad located just
outside the entrance to the temple which
was present before Syria's Awakening and
applies very strongly that the temple
was the home of an older Sage now how do
we connect the poe sisters to the old
sage of the Forest Temple you're
probably wondering simple the identity
of the previous Sage of the forest is
the poe sisters or should I say Amy and
the identity of the previous Sage of
fire is Joelle the previous Sage of
water is Beth and the previous Sage of
Shadow would be Meg I know that's a tad
weird to conceptualize but think about
it if the force nipple was built by a
richer royal family that has to be the
poe sisters and since they built a
castle and hid inside that would also
make sense if they were sages who needed
to be protected from potential threats
and if the hidden room underneath the
castle that's littered with Triforce
emblems all over the platform is some
sort of old prayer room where the sages
would go to pray to the gods it would
also make sense sense that they were
each sages of their own Elements which
is why they together were the only ones
that could open the way to the Triforce
prayer room by combining their Flames
Each of which were different colors
which is also a very key sage-ism the
only Sage that would be missing from
this picture would be the sage of spirit
who was reawakened as naburu in the
adult timeline however there are Gerudo
blocks located inside the Forest Temple
so perhaps the previous Sage of spirit
was also a Gerudo who had close ties
with the sage sisters in life and
provided them with some materials for
the castle it also makes sense for the
poe sisters to be the sage sisters since
they were probably still alive up until
Ganondorf cursed the Forest Temple with
an evil wind which probably means he
entered inside killed the sisters
turning him into malicious ghosts and
corrupting the prayer room with a
phantom copy of himself the biggest
piece of evidence against this
explanation however would be the
Triforce warping pads located in all the
other temples such as the fire water
Shadow and spirit Temple as well as the
Temple of Time also when the new sages
are awakened most of them at least imply
that they're meant to protect their
respective Elemental temples which would
suggest that the ancient sages lived in
each of these respective places but
given the evidence we've been going over
regarding their possible former
identities as the poe sisters it could
be that most of them had retreated into
the stronghold I.E the Forest Temple
once the hyrulean civil war broke out
amongst the other races of Hyrule it
would also explain why the sage of
spirit likely an old Gerudo would have
stayed away as the land of the Gerudo is
considered to be outside the borders of
Hyrule but we've spent enough time going
over the Forest Temple and while this
isn't a perfect explanation it does wrap
up most if not all of the questions that
people have regarding the mysterious
Fortress moving on though the next
dungeon we're going to cover is the
water temple and to be honest I actually
kind of sort of completely covered this
in my first lore of the video the one
covering the bosses of Ocarina of Time
actually I kind of covered a lot of this
in that video but you know what I said I
was gonna do the dungeon video so here
we are but anyway if you watched that
one you probably know where I'm going
with this but if you have haven't
allowed me to Briefly summarize
basically according to good old kapora
gabora aka raru the ancient Sage of
light the water temple was built by the
Zora to worship the water Spirits I
personally believe that the puzzle-like
structure is so puzzling in its
structure because the completion of the
temple is in and of itself a form of
worship from the Zora people a journey
that would purify the mind and body and
speaking of purifying the mind that's
also why I think the Dark Link room was
created it's a completely hallucinogenic
room that's entire purpose is to become
a dark reflection of the traveler
looking to conquer the temple and for
proof of this that I actually didn't
mention in the previous video just pay
attention to Ling's own reflection in
the water as he progresses through the
room he starts off with it but once he
crosses the tree in the center his
reflection is gone and has emerged as
Dark Link created by the room who awaits
to challenge The Traveler with a fight
directly from the depths of their own
heart Navi even confirms that Dark Link
is none other than link himself so this
makes sense obviously Ganondorf had some
shenanigans against that play here
sticking a weird water sucking but also
water producing amoeba known as amorpha
inside the temple but that's a topic or
rather was a topic for another video for
a bit more of an in-depth explanation on
the temple ironically feel free to check
out the lore of the bosses video on
Ocarina of Time last but not least let's
talk Spirit Temple and oh boy this is a
fun one starting as always with the
in-game factual pieces of lore were
given the spirit Temple is a well Temple
located deep within the desert of the
Gerudo across an area so plagued by
sandstorms that it's referred to as the
haunted Wasteland and it actually is
haunted you even have to follow a Pogue
to cross this section safely but once
you do you're met with the desert
Colossus which is a giant depiction of
the goddess of the sand which is most
likely actually hylia herself but for
more information on all the logic and
evidence behind that check out Bandit's
previous Skyward Sword boss lore video
there's also the Triforce warping pad
here that would imply a highly a
connection as well inside the desert
Colossus rests the hidden Spirit Temple
which pry prior to the events of the
game served as a hideout for naburu and
her followers until Ganondorf Rose to
power after which it was referred to as
The Hideout of Ganondorf and his goons
oh and his mothers or mother it's
complicated anyway after link is able to
solve the problems the temple presents
both as a kid and as an adult naburu
awakens as the new Sage of spirit and
well that just about sums up everything
we know for a fact about the dungeon
from the game itself so now let's
speculate lots of fans believe that the
spirit Temple could have become the also
very well-known arbiter's grounds
dungeon from Twilight Princess
especially since the encyclopedia flat
out states that the grounds are
connected to the spirit temple in those
exact words and nothing more actually
but as I went over in the Twilight
Princess dungeon video there are several
reasons to believe that the arbiter's
grounds is actually much older than the
spirit Temple and that it was built for
an entirely different purpose the two
locations are connected by both being
located within the expansive Gerudo
desert and about the appearances of the
goddess of the sand but that's about it
according to the official Ocarina of
Time game guide the spirit Temple was
built by the ancestors of the Gerudo and
given that the entire thing is built
within a giant statue of a goddess I'd
wager that it's a pretty safe bet that
the spear Temple was always meant to be
a place of worship for the sand goddess
especially given the fact that there is
another giant statue of the same
individual located inside and honestly
there's not too much more to be said
about it I mean in either case whether
the sand goddess actually represents
hylia or another unknown deity it makes
sense that if the arbitus grounds was
built as a worship by combat Arena thing
the spirit Temple would instead be built
as more of a worship through church
thing I guess but also in line with the
strange appearance of the sand goddess
would be the strange appearances of
several other symbols present in the
dungeon for instance outside the
entrance to the temple slash on the
bottom of the desert Colossus statue
there are serpents depicted eating one
another in the 3DS version these
serpents are green this is oddly similar
to the oroboros-like symbol from tears
of the Kingdom's recent trailer and for
a whole bunch of reasons that I don't
have time to go into in this video could
also be used as further proof for the
sand god is highly identity thing the
other strange symbol would be the flying
or winged eyeball symbol located above
some of the doorways astute fans will
immediately recognize the connection
between this depiction and another
well-known Zelda villain known as vati a
connection could also be Loosely drawn
between vati and the sheikah and then
between the ancient Chica and the
ancient Builders of the spirit Temple
but that is so much speculation said in
so little time so we'll just end that
right now in a nutshell though we know
as much about the spear Temple as we
don't know but what we do know at least
so far seems to point to the simple
conclusion of an ancient worship site
for an ancient deity built by ancient
ancestors of the Gerudo which eventually
twin Rover set up camping and started
brainwashing other Garuda women fun
stuff but there you have it the complete
list of all the Dungeons and dungeons oh
yeah the complete list of half of the
dungeons in Ocarina of Time sir maze any
ideas as to where these lore crazed
Zelda Fanatics can find the other half
of the list well my friend I have just
the answer I mean it is a collab
operation so it shouldn't be a big
mystery where the other half is but for
those who don't know me the missing four
can be found over on my channel monster
maze where I cover everything Zelda and
more mostly Zelda but I do have my wacky
moments anyway to miss the Bandit I say
thank you as always for inviting me over
it's always a pleasure working with you
and uh yeah I'm just gonna stop talking
now goodbye thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video or at
least our efforts into making it please
consider leaving a like to get it spread
around on YouTube and subscribe if you
haven't already because we are doing
some awesome stuff here at Bandit games
and together we can make this channel
really something special also the videos
will only get more interesting from here
so yeah stick around huge thanks as
always to my banded crew of which I have
some names to announce say hello to
Mickey p and Nick L who recently joined
up on patreon thank you guys so much I
do what I do because of you that's all
I've got for this one so be sure to
follow me on my socials and I will see
you over on Monster maze's Channel this
is Bandit of the heading over there
peace
[Music]
thank you